foreign
Abigail is in Topeka Kansas hi Abigail
how are you
well hello there thank you for taking my
call Dave and Rachel sure what's up
well you both say that that's not a
money problem that's a marriage problem
and I know that's what I have I've been
married 40 years and I'm staying in the
marriage but I'm scared I have no
retirement to speak of we have no
retirement to speak of and we're getting
old
um how old are you guys
he's 69 on 62. yeah
and you have
you guys have no retirement
he has uh 40 000 I have 16
000.
are you all still working
yes
um he he's had very substandary
businesses over the years he sold uh his
last one and then quote retired for two
and a half years and now he's back in
the workforce we make plenty of money we
just spend it all
hmm and what's his
what's his hesitation of well you're
saying we spend it all so
I'm gonna go with that language is it
mostly him or is it you as well that
you're thinking I I don't have great
money habits either
we don't have Furs and jewels we have
nothing really to show for it we've been
doing a budget for four years after we
did FPU
and yet no matter how much money we
bring in out the door it goes and last
night he said to me
that gazelle intensity is BS I'm not
doing it well we've completely paid off
all the debt well let me just say we did
and then
I did again and again and again
and
what's what's really got me scared right
now is his health is failing and even
though I'm a late bloomer I was a
stay-at-home mom for years and years
um I have the capacity to make a lot of
money with all the
stress I it's just wildly
like last year with 50 Grand this year
is 175 Grand the year before two years
ago it was 185 so it's back it could be
a low year it could be a high Year we're
not putting anything away what do you do
and now I need a new car what do you do
and he wants to go into debt for the car
what do you do
don't laugh I'm an attorney and I have
my own business
but it can fluctuate wildly oh why would
we laugh
it's not funny it's wonderful
congratulations
pretty cool
um and you have the ability to make
really good money show them yours yeah
uh
I
um
everything we would tell you
um
short of fixing this in the marriage
counselor's office is a poor substitute
and at best a Band-Aid or at worst would
cause more damage to the marriage
um marriage counseling I'm I'm tempted
no this guy I mean I get I get where you
are I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm just
saying if I tell you to do something
else part of the problem is I got 20
million people listening it might give
one of them permission to do something
else and I don't want them to do it
um I want them to I want to get them to
the root of this and to fix it but um
in if you're going to stay married maybe
you need to act like you're divorced
record account yep
he doesn't have access to your income
anymore
yeah and you make 195 000 you can go buy
a car pay cash for it a car that fits
you know within your cash budget and you
just operate your little life there
and um
um
it's but I gotta tell you it's not it's
not that's not a good way to live
is that because of her age no it's just
not a good way relationally no I'm
saying you're going to be living in a
house with a roommate now
I know and that's where it first I don't
like you I'm like I
you know yes because we say that it's
it's more of a marriage issue than a
money issue it's coming out as a money
issue but there's something about him
that isn't willing or doesn't want to be
on the same page with you and be a team
with you for the rest of your marriage
and you guys can still have another 20
years of this life together and so I
would want to get to the root of of of
his
his pushback so much you know what is it
because he he's smart I mean he can look
at numbers and know we don't have money
to retire and is it is it a pride thing
is it a fear thing like what is it in
him that refuses to say I'm gonna I'm
gonna stop spending everything I make
and put it away for the good of of my
future and my wife's future and all of
that like I wanna
I wanna know more of what what's going
on in him and all of that yeah I agree I
I
um I can't believe you said separate
accounts uh well I'm
you know I I said it was 73 caveats but
the uh um uh what I'm saying and and I'm
trying to get to why you said that is it
because of her age and she's going to
retire soon and she needs money to live
off of like or is it because most okay
what needs to happen
is
she needs to lay down the thing and say
if we're not going to do this together
we're not going to be together
after 40 years
you know that eventually it's going to
get down to that uh because her level of
respect for him is going down and down
and down and down and down now she's
being very careful to be very classy but
in between all those words was a lot of
anger and disrespect which I would feel
the same way and like most people would
yeah and she's like you know this guy's
baggage and
um you know I'm smart enough I'm an
attorney at late in life I became an
attorney and I can go do this and I
don't I don't need this crap that's all
in there and it's not going to get
better if you separate the accounts it's
going to get worse yep
because you're going to watch him over
there in this plane in the sewage and
you're over here playing with gold coins
and so
um it's just a problem so I mean Sharon
I've been married 40 years and I can
tell you what would happen at our house
uh we would go and sit with a counselor
and we would try to find common ground
and if she bowed up and said I I
absolutely refuse to be smart I am going
to spend like I'm in Congress and we are
going to be on welfare as we go into our
retirement years because I am prideful
and I will not deal with this and I'm
not going to face this and I'm not going
to discuss it
um then she's going to find her own way
I guess it'd be really sad I hate that
but I I because the alternative is
actually worse yeah
it's actually worse
so um yeah I would put him in a corner
but I mean I'll do it systematically
kindly gently lovingly patiently yep but
I'm gonna put him in a corner and we're
gonna solve this because this ain't
gonna work out yeah I'm not gonna look
across the room at you and hate you 10
years from now I'm not gonna do it